quando convidaram para fazer essa tese
disseram que o tema nunca a minha
primeira reação foi votado porque está
exatamente o que eu faço e posso
aguentar montanhas novos é exatamente
simpatiquíssimo pra fazer mas quando
quiser e é isso que eu fazia durante
esta este minutos que tenho à minha
disposição mas vou tentar ter o desafio
dos falar de números sem colocar números
daquelas que desafiar o euro devolve a
pergunta que todos os alguns novos
componentes vão tentar apenas a pensar
como é que nós temos termos outra forma
o primeiro ponto quando falamos em
economia em números é que nós temos nos
grandes por alguns programas escritos
agora pelo são paulo
nós temos mais o que só olhar os prédios
lógica dos números nós temos muitos
agentes econômicos temos muitas decisões
que são tomadas todos os dias nem
extraordinário como é que nós temos
mecanismos que coordenam as decisões
todas vocês pensarem um exemplo clássico
economia que era que o que é preciso
para produzir um lápis um
desenvolvimento firme e quantas decisões
têm que ser coordenadas por quantos
agentes econômicos a pescar o lápis é
votar
se nós pensarmos que hoje em dia temos
muitas decisões
muitos agentes tomam sem saber o que os
outros vão fazer mas precisam uns dos
outros em impressionante quando os meus
problemas em três problemas de
coordenação
temos não é só dos grandes abordagens
uma que é muito carente diria que
arranjar um modelo de otimização por
exemplo para distribuir medicamentos em
pontos de venda otimizar e ter as faltas
outra coisa é que eu posso fazer isso de
uma forma descentralizada sem fazer
assim da organização como é que um
enquadramento para os grandes números
dirigentes tomarem suas decisões
individualmente eles querem o mesmo
resultado
então um dos desafios dos grandes
números dos números muito grandes na
economia é como é que nós fazemos
mecanismos centralizados e
descentralizados da utilização do
recurso
então nós temos aqui total dos preços
temos aqui as pessoas procuram é
maximizar ao ter o melhor bial entanto
elas terão uma espécie de benchmarking
de mecanismos econômicos escuridão com
- quando falamos em quando vou agora
falo do pib
alguém sabe exatamente como é que se
constrói o pib o que é o pib
fala se tanto na técnica a meta é somar
todo o valor acrescentado gerado na
economia aumentou não porque é o valor
acrescentado gerado na economia dos
sonos mas estamos tendo a sua base
decisões pelos agentes econômicos também
é como é que nós conseguimos encontrar
essas regiões como os ajudamos a
melhorar essas prisões entanto temos
grandinos muito grande economia que
obrigam os interistas um centralização
outra atualização mas também temos um
dos pequenos que envolvem interações
entre no mercado de gêmeos por exemplo
temos que lidar com o monopólio ou
oligopólio
em termos de mercados como é que essa
interação é feita e vai ter uma forma
diferente
nós temos também nos pequenos na
componente económica que quis traçar uma
riqueza comportamentos diferentes e fica
muitas vezes não sair com a minha não
podem ser desligados do comportamento
dos agentes econômicos que gostam e
talvez a sua parte faz mais enfrenta a
economia e os números da economia dos
números mostrarem que a economia não vai
só pensar em contar os números não vai
só também fazer a outra parte é só
contar a história da origem isso não
pensar como é que nós juntarmos o
comportamento das sessões das pessoas
quanto quiserem por um caminho que se
cozinha aqui está à vontade com os
pequenos números cocada cada um faz e
essa partida é temos ao mesmo tempo que
nos números tendo de interações grandes
nomes muita gente economics tona a
questão de quais são os números que eu
quero usar a economia a olhar para os
problemas
estivemos a falar dos problemas do
comércio internacional
eu quero olhar para vê-los exportações
quanto ex-deputado quanto é importante
são os ramos entrou em funcionamento os
estatutos ouviram falar nos últimos
tempos a do senhor do outro lado do
atlântico o chamado no trampo twittar
vai impor tarifas sobre o aço e alumínio
e nós pensarmos uma coisa grande no
último mês as exportações para coisas
pelos nomes que é como lidar com
eventuais guerras comerciais entre china
e
estados unidos têm a ver com pequenos
nos dois países têm também com a mãe ana
sempre muito nessa tensão da grande
número por um lado muita gente exporta
muita gente importa não conseguimos
centralmente dizer que ela não vai
importar e exportar
depois temos decisões que afetam isso
tem a ver com quem nos números quando se
soltou e dirigentes sobre isso
solicitamos que nós temos aqui em natal
individualmente como em quase todas as
áreas
esta tensão em grande número de pequenos
núcleos
uma das coisas que mais nos ensina
quando tem que falar sobre economia e
outra coisa qualquer mas casas ou
números
é preciso que as pessoas muitas vezes
têm que a economia é contar coisas
contatando acumular numa certa forma
estamos ansiosos em que nós olhamos para
a economia começa começa a tensão entre
nos grandes e nos pequenos
um dos aspectos que vamos ter aqui além
de contar coisas anos tem que brincar a
charla paulo a atividade da análise
econômica não é só contar não termina aí
só começa aí é parte fundamental dos
santos análise econômica em cima desses
números é o primeiro as coisas para além
do óbvio todo o trabalho de alonso o que
está lá com o imediatamente visível por
exemplo quando a balança quando só
falando novamente o senhor trânsito e
decisões político é o time em pequenos
novos talentos arroz todos ouviram falar
qual era uma das principais promessas
eleitorais que eu tenha do uol
o muro certo tem que pagar 11 anos
como é que os mexicanos vão pagar um
muro
vamos impor uma tarifa sobre as
importações do méxico para os estados
unidos
era o que eu era quando eu tanto em
grande número e funciona porque exporta
muito foi uma tarefa que eu escolhi
muitos milhões tanta que consegue fazer
muitos milhões
tínhamos várias crianças que logo seguro
que o problema traz análises econômicas
eu lançaram em curso sobre um agente
econômico e neste caso também fazer um
imposto que quem sofre com esse imposto
não dependo formalmente realmente quem
tem que pagar a pena como o
comportamento dos agentes econômicos que
justa e sim
em particular os mexicanos querem eu
consigo escutar o mesmo preço vocês não
quiserem não compreende a tarifa sobre
os impostos sobre os produtos mexicanos
trazer um aumento do preço no consumidor
americano
quem poderia ser o consumidor americano
limita os mexicanos dissessem nós já
estamos completamente e queremos que o
preço que o consumidor seja o mesmo da
tarifa
então nesse caso seria verdade entre o
produtor mexicano poderia pegar isso
então só olhar os números sem olhar para
este momento de comportamento que está
em cima dos números dar a provar metros
costas em jardas que é só a partir daí
começa agora até agora falei muito
grande nos 1500 tensão que está em como
elas interagem
mas também temos outra visão do lateral
em termos muito grande temos muitos
números chamado de gaita essa sim deve
ser bastante maior
mas quero ter muitos números traz uma
alteração da forma de de naus e traz
além das necessidades técnicas
equipamentos pessoas desde domingo muito
melhor do que os economistas torna a
questão de saber o que se torna valioso
nisso e separamos bem o que vai passar a
ter valor
nesse tempo ter muitos números não é
muito mas é saber o que é que eu faço
conhecimento - mas foi uma experiência
com muitos pequenos nos expõe todas as
pessoas tenham algum vez em quando algum
prazer em comer pão com manteiga pão com
algum tipo de acerto com a gente amanhã
promete para combater uma verdadeira de
possuir uma manteiga provopar em nosso
mercado
vocês têm que comprar manteiga e das
penta em 322 variantes manteiga uma
situação dessas pra escolher uma entre
ontem que cinco pessoas manteiga e sal
na água com sal ea manteiga do alentejo
coisa já qual é a situação que ajuda
mais
atenas 5 terá 122 certo
a primeira canção entrar num país com os
estados unidos
vamos pedir um café uma sanduicheira
pronta qualquer capital abcd oi ao cair
will power agora quer que querem cima
tipo se ela quer em cima fica pra essas
coisas
muitos não se pode não ser
necessariamente com isso ela também
neste momento tanto o aumento do valor
bastará que não quer que nós fazemos com
esses números saber guiar qual é a
pergunta certa com as crianças eram os
números e ter capacidade de distinguir o
que vale a pena ser analisada e que não
vale a pena ser analisado
significa que nós temos muitos números
antes de cruzar dois tipos de
competências dois tipos de vencimento em
1º como trabalhar com escandinavos uma
unidade muito grande
depois saber o que é valioso olhar para
isso necessitamos por exemplo preciso
treinamento pelo olhar pra programa
estamos no nosso sistema de saúde é
olhar para as transações individuais são
muitas e ver que são auckland que são
carlos ronalsa pp o fatah movimento da
tensão fralda não somente vocês já
repararam que nos últimos 23 anos quatro
anos talvez tem vivido vez enquanto não
tem chope fraude informações
a atração que é feita que não existe
como é que isso tudo é que surge esse
aspecto pode surgir denúncias mas não
tem medo não tem sido essa situação tem
sido porque pela transação que é
realizada da queda do entenda formação
em andamento no país é a china estava
isso é uma série de informação associada
quem escreveu em winton atleta consegue
perceber um terminal no segmento das
pequenas têm muito mais vendas numa
farmácia consciente obscuro apartamento
não há doentes que justifiquem é que o
volume de transações pós laboral que a
pessoa está motorização grande número
muitos números é em termos de perceber
mesmo só temos aí também temos outras
áreas nuclear durante toda a corrida o
comportamento do consumidor em termos o
comércio a retalho luciana vestimos
vocês podem não acreditar mas
compra uma coisa no supermercado a
transação que estarão em exposição
fizeram-se conquistado algum lado e
tenho a certeza na algum sítio alguém
vai estar a olhar país tentando obter o
cartão de fidelidade do continente ou
pingo possa junto só ter o desconto
estão informar o organista quais são os
nossos hábitos de compra e vai procurar
o vosso hábito não vai perceber as
irregularidades e perceber que a
diferença é que se pode fazer perceber
isso mudará as cervejas da plataforma de
cima da plataforma de baixo sem algum
efeito no número de vendas que eu tenho
que ser baixa isso é uma atualização em
economia desses grandes e nós temos
tempo muitas outras
mas se eu falar em termos muitos números
também encaminha consegue funcionar sem
nos ia pesar da taxa que dizer que os
números não enganam terminais
vamos nos enganar às vezes funcionar sem
nomes também pode ser interessante
porque funcionar sem números obriga a
construir um quadro conceptual que pode
pois todos seus princípios dos quais nós
temos que olhar pra ambos então por
exemplo eu posso só numa passou
trabalhando sem nome que eu posso pensar
com cuidado o que eu quero saber é que
eu vou à procura
a partir daí eu posso ver como é que os
primeiros números da organização é que
eles roubaram que nós quer fazer se quer
concluir uma análise sobre números nos
alunos e isso é muito na parte do
convento de seiça o movimento não só que
cada vez mais qualquer empresa que
funciona no mercado qualquer entidade
pública que funciona no seu campo de
atividade seja marcada não acaba por ter
que usar números que não enganem
prossegue saber o que quer fazer com
isso e hoje ele já começa a ser
frequente encontrarmos entidades dizem o
que nós queremos essa informação tomba
que eu faço agora com ela
ajudamos a organizar isto é isso e no
endereço a questão é que você quer saber
um dos aspectos que em tribunal na área
da saúde
começamos a ter que começar a surgir
algumas bases internacionais que
atualmente algumas nacionais também com
essa informação é o que que a relação
entre o doente
o médico a instituição financeira que é
feita ea farmácia vai como é que isto se
articula eu conseguir as pessoas assim
agora eu preciso saber o que quer saber
se estamos todos quer saber como é que a
relação médico doente como elas articula
quer saber se o doente valoriza ou não
ter a capacidade de escolher um genérico
através da escolha que fez na farmácia
quer saber o que seus membros que
ganharem a quantidade de números em si
mas não adianta nada se não tiver feito
um trabalho sem nome
antes disso outro aspecto a minha é
construir num exemplo a inflação eo pib
só novos construídos não existe
naturalmente você contar pessoas mas a
idéia do tipo não existe em si mesmo
o pib faça um carro ser somas todos que
existe no caso da inflação é uma zona
com grava da luz numa construção e
consolidação econômica não é também
muito é construção de outros números
procuram criar um mapa dos ter dois
sistemas econômicos do sistema de
contabilidade nacional a mãozinha um
simples golo de deus muito a explicar o
que é que nós porque nós usamos um deus
econômicos olhar para a realidade é que
alguns esse um dos equipamentos em
números o que não tem por que algumas
pessoas para chegar aqui buscar aquela
humilhação ou utilizam hoje em dia o
google maps ou similares ao todo já o
começo do ano o google maps google maps
em dois tipos de vista tem vista mapa
tem esse perfil e também é ouviu
quando vocês querem um sítio ou outro
voltar a utilizar o street view outros o
primeiro mapa e prover a porta pois não
se feriu
a nasa que não funciona muito nesse
plano
dados do mapa eo google maps mapa
depois do time esse objetivo olhar para
o objetivo que nós possamos ter
frequentemente curva abc a construir
números que nos dêem esse mapa
queremos também criar um de outra forma
temos claro que já me engano economics
permite conhecer econômicas de preços
econômicos próximos ea técnica etapas
com coisas mas não é por enquanto a
decisão das ruas que escolham alguém e
pretendem frear a opção o seu
comportamento é criarmos esse nos
permitir criar números permitem
compreender melhor o comportamento das
pessoas de suas escolhas
podemos também ter números falam demais
nós começamos há detalhes que o
acompanhamento das pessoas queremos ter
mais vigiadas aspectos da sua vida
falando mais acrescenta depois do
escândalo da campeã olímpica em santos
foram nos falaram mais
enquanto temos muitos nomes também podem
implicar nós temos que ter questões de
confidencialidade de petróleo
privacidade
no entanto os números são associados a
pessoas passou sem número em frente dos
outros
enquanto para uns mais iguais do que
outros né pra também para a economia mas
nos finais presta a prestação primeira
análise econômica coisa muito não só
nacional está a mudar
campos próximos como engenharia 70 e em
seguida informar o conceito de
computação ajudamos muito nisso mas no
fim quem caminha pelo menos os números
não conseguir as idéias os lobos vão
ajudar as idéias pelo menos no momento e
não substituímos a decisão
o mali o comportamento humano pelos
vamos fazer uma descrição um mapa dessas
prisões do real
[Aplausos]